- But you're from- not Houston.
Is it Katy?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- My- a couple of my band
members are from Beaumont.
That whole area.
- Oh yeah, sure.
I actually went to elementary school
on the east side over
there near Beaumont, so.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- [Renee] Yeah.
- Do you ever- do you
get back there often?
- The last time I was
there, I think, you know,
I drive through a lot, you know?
Cuz I'll drive out to Austin.
I like to road trip and uh, and
I'll head down occasionally.
I went to my fifth grade teacher's
retirement a couple years ago.
Mr. Matson and-
- Oh my god I love that.
- Yeah, he became the
high school librarian.
So he's kind of, you know- we, we follow,
he was with us through until
we- my class until we graduated
and yeah.
I couldn't recognize my town.
It grew so much it's crazy.
- Oh my gosh, me too.
I left and I came back.
It was just like, even a few years later.
And I was like, this is like a metropolis.
- [Renee] Yeah. It's crazy.
Like what? We had like a Walmart.
That was all we had when I was here.
What happened?
- You know, we got a mall.
- You got real cool when
I left, like whatever.
What's the hardest part though
for you for getting used
to L.A.- minus traffic.
- Oh, interesting.
Okay. It was that crosswalk,
you know, the crosswalk where-
cuz usually if somebody
stops in the left lane it's
cuz they're gonna turn left
and so you'll go around them
but not not in, in LA
it's because there's like
there's a human, there's
a human in the road
and you have to learn not
to go around the person
- [Kelly] To not hit the pedestrians.
- Correct.
Don't kill anybody.
That's that was the big part.
That's a good lesson.
- Don't kill anybody!
That and the billboards.
Do you remember that when you got to town?
- Yeah.
- The enormity of them,
you drop down Sunset
Boulevard and I'm sure anybody
who's visited- and it
is remarkable, isn't it?
- It's kind of overwhelming though.
- It is.
I mean, they're all layered.
It looks kind of like it's-
- I literally, when I moved
here after high school-
I was like 18 when I moved here
and it was right after high school
and I remember going on
Sunset and I was like,
there was almost too much happening.
I couldn't- and then I'm like,
how do people not wreck daily here?
Just looking at everything?
- [Renee] Yeah.
- It's like, yeah.
- The stimuli stimuli.
Yeah. It's it's it's a lots overwhelming.
It's true.
And it feels like- it's almost
like- there's so much noise
that they gotta get bigger
and louder and bigger
and louder and nobody notices
it at all or something.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't know.
- And do you want them to
notice it while they're
behind the wheel?
I don't know.
- [Renee] Then there's that part.
- Do you remember, though,
the first time your
face was on a billboard?
(Renee laughs)
Cause that's fun.
I remember mine.
It was like a radio station I think.
They put my face to like
another artist or whatever
for a radio station.
I was like, my face is on a giant board.
I was like, I have made it.
- I remember the first time
your face was on a giant board.
- Do you remember yours?
- A lot of us remember
the first time your face
was on a giant board.
- Aw, you're so nice.
I just thought it was really cool.
I was like "wow".
I dunno why they wanted me
up there, but it happened.
- Well we know why (laughs).
- What, what was your experience like?
Do you remember?
- Well, I just remember that
I had a lot of films come out-
a bunch of films come out
and they didn't need me to
be on the billboard (laughs).
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
So it's like the other person's on the-
- [Renee] I barely made the movie.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Like I barely made the movie-
- [Kelly] Well, look at you now.
- I didn't need me on the-
Aw, that's sweet.
That's sweet.
- Do you, do you, whenever- I
know you said you go to Austin
do you miss Texas food?
I love Texas food.
- It's you know, it's funny.
When I make my plans with my friends,
it's always around where we're gonna eat.
- Abs- why not?
Absolutely.
- How many times we could
cram tacos into the schedule.
You, you know, that's-
- [Kelly] 'Cause it's Tex Mex.
- 'Cause it's Tex Mex.
- Yes.
It's different than here.
So when I moved here, I was
like, what is this Mexican?
It's probably authentic Mexican food.
- Why is there mango in my salsa?
- I know I was like, why?
Why? And there's strawberries?
Is that new for guac?
Okay cool.
- Why is my, why is my
iced tea passion fruit?
Like what?
- [Kelly] Yeah. I just want a normal one.
- I just want a lemon.
- Yeah, it is-
I love Tex Mex though.
That's my favorite thing.
And I- I thought that maybe
you might mix- miss it.
So I, I brought you something.
- [Renee] I do miss- What?
- Okay, here we go.
I'm I'm a polite host.
I'm a polite host.
You have a drink and some queso.
- [Renee] I dunno.
- Okay no, wait, wait, hold on.
Sit down for a minute.
Wait. Cause here's the thing I have been-
this is season three.
Since season one, I have
been searching for, like,
good queso in LA.
This queso is from Roadside
Taco right here in Studio City.
Shout out because it's awesome.
- [Renee] Okay.
- I'm not even being paid by them.
I just really love this queso.
- It does look good
- But I need you to, like
maybe, do you wanna taste?
- I'm in.
- Okay, we have our own.
We have our own.
- [Renee] Is this mean?
'Cause everybody's leaning
forward over there.
- [Kelly] I don't know
but my mouth is watering
and I'm so excited.
- [Renee] I know- I'm
little happy about it.
Oh, you guys.
- Oh no.
I'd like to apologize in advance
cuz this looks really good.
- It's good.
It needs to be warmed up
a tiny bit, but whatever.
It's really good.
- I mean-
- But I like it when
it's warmed up heavily.
It's like really runny-
That's what I love.
- I, I don't, you know what-
if it gets better than that?
I, my, my head might blow off.
It is so good.
- I know.
It's so hard to find good queso here.
- Cheers.
- Cheers. Oh, I drank before.
That's like rude.
Oh, I like your ring!
- Ladies- ladies and
gentlemen, Kelly Carson.
Thank you. What sweet thing to do.